[Music]
damien
hey damian it's willie here from woop
how are you
good how are you yeah awesome uh
is now a good time to talk
yeah nathan's gold oh worried awesome so
well
my name is willie and i'm the marketing
director for woo
hey mate nice to meet you yeah you too
and uh
okay i came across your name and the
client base
and i see that you're using our product
now
yeah yeah i just started using that this
is my first week actually
how are you finding it so just just oh
that's
awesome it's very um easy well you know
like
especially after training just come home
it's probably 15 20 minutes it's perfect
oh that's i've been here three nights
but it may have been good branched out
what i've eaten
compared to what i usually eat and
food's good mate and it's just like
the best thing about it's like quick
yeah you buddy and
you don't have to prep anything until
now
loved it this week so far that's great
great to hear and i've spoken to greg
because we've got a bit of a problem
he mentioned that yesterday yeah we got
a bit of a proposal for you
and he he was pretty impressed with it
um but he obviously wanted you to uh
be all over it as well so we're looking
looking to start a um whoop calendar
yep and i know that i've i've been a big
fan of your jockey shoots that you've
done
previously yep you
you obviously got pretty good looks and
a really good body that we're looking to
sort of tap
into because you've got that profile as
well
okay yep so um the plan of the uh we've
already got aaron smith on board he's
already signed up
so you obviously know him quite well yep
so what we're looking to do is sort of a
nude calendar shoot but using
fruit or vegetables to cover our cover
your bits
yeah how does that sound
i thought you'd be all over it with your
sort of jockey background
different different if i've got my graph
on but yeah okay well
that's right
um i've seen your jockey shoots and
we'll obviously probably need some
pretty big fruit for you i'd imagine
wouldn't we
[ __ ] there is anything made of work
yeah so um we're looking to try and get
you on sort of the september or december
page yep
so are you are you pretty interested in
this
oh yeah like you'd have to probably just
go through greg mate and just put the
finer details of it all and
yeah and um and go through him and then
use that
you know what happens and he liaises
with me and yeah
on what's required so um
to see what he reckons uh what what you
guys have
got in place like like the finer detail
i mean
yeah yeah i'm sure we'll work around it
what piece of
like just so we could start planning
what piece of fruit would you prefer
because we've got
range obviously from big size to
watermelon
all the way down to blueberries
willie from work
and there's actually willie from work
yeah
oh yeah okay um
oh
[Laughter]
oh